Now that we've declared
z to be an optional,
let's try to use z in an operation.
Let's take a look at this error.
Here the compiler is telling us
that z needs to be unwrapped.
You can't use a present
that's still wrapped.
Now to unwrap z, we could just follow
the suggestion from the compiler and
place an exclamation
mark after z like this.
But when unwrapping optionals,
we want to be as careful as possible, so
we're going to learn the safest
way to unwrap a variable.
Here we can see that this 123 string
will convert to an int with no problem.
But what if we weren't so sure?
Here is a scenario in which z
might actually evaluate to nil.
I've created an array with two items and
an index that is randomly either 0 or 1.
When I get this string from the array,
I can't be sure whether it can
be converted to an end value.
I don't know whether z will be nil or
not.
How do we unwrap z safely so that we
can use it in further operations?
Swift uses the, if let, construction
to carefully unwrap optionals.
Take the time to really
study this expression.
It'll come up frequently
in your Swift projects.
This is the expression
that unwraps z and
places the int into
a plain old int variable.
In this case, we named it int value, but
there's not a strict naming convention.
This unwrapping and
initializing of int value is also a
Boolean expression controlling this if.
It serves two purposes, and
it will only evaluate to true if
the optional has an int value.
If the optional stores nil, then the
whole expression will evaluate to false.
Inside the block, the variable intValue
has been initialized as an int and
can safely be used.
And we can use an else block for
the nil case.
To see both cases,
you can rerun the Playground.
Just go up to the Editor's
menu > Execute Playground.
You can see the results
over here on the sidebar.
Just click on this little eyeball,.
And I'll run it again.
And again.
[LAUGH] Sometimes I get a value and
sometimes I don't.
In this example, I chose variable
names to make the code easier to read.
But a convention adopted by many
developers is to name the unwrapped
variable to match the wrapped variable,
like this.
This can be a little confusing at first,
but
you'll get used to it after
you see it a few times.
You don't have to adopt
to this convention, but
you may find that it saves time.
This way you don't have to come up with
a new name for every unwrapped variable.
Safely unwrapping optionals like this
is a fundamental Swift skill, and
one can't have too much practice.
Let's walk through another
example with UIImageView.
Here I've created a UIImageView
which has a UIImage property.
This UIImage property
is a UIImage optional.
In this example, we'd like to access the
size property of this UIImage optional.
If I try to access the image
property directly to get the size,
the compiler complains.
Since there's no guarantee that this
image property contains a value,
we'll need to unwrap it carefully.
So we use if let to
declare a variable and
initialize it with
the unwrapped image property.
If the image has a value,
we can access its size.
If the image is nil,
we're still covered.
Let's say we hadn't set the image yet.
In that case,
the else block gets executed.
And here we can see
the image hasn't been set.
And if we do go ahead and set the image
to something, here we can see its size.
And now that it's unwrapped, we can also
expand the image from within Playground.